The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So today,
more parallel programming, as
we will do for the next couple
lectures as well.
So today, we're going to
look at how to analyze
multi-threaded algorithms, and
I'm going to start out with a
review of what I hope most of
you know from 6006 or 6046,
which is how to solve divide
and conquer recurrences.
Now, we know that we can solve
them with recursion trees, and
that gets tedious after a while,
so I want to go through
the so-called Master Method to
begin with, and then we'll get
into the content
of the course.
But it will be very helpful,
since we're going to do so
many divide and conquer
recurrences.
The difference between these
divide and conquer recurrences
and the ones for caching is that
caching is all tricky by
the base condition.
Here, are all the recurrences
are going to be nice and
clean, just like you learn
in your algorithms class.
So we'll start with talking
about it, and then we'll go
through several examples of
analysis of algorithms.
And it'll also tell us something
about what we need
to do to make our
code go fast.
So the main method we're
going to use is
called the Master Method.
It's for solving recurrences of
the form t of n equals a t
of n over b plus f of n, where
we have some technical
conditions, a is greater than
or equal to 1, b is greater
than one, and f is
asymptotically positive.
As f gets large, it
becomes positive.
When we give a recurrence like
this, normally if the base
case is order one, it's
convention not give it, to
just assume, yeah, we understand
that when n is
small enough, the result
is constant.
As I say, that's the place where
this differs from the
way that we solve recurrences
for caching, where you have to
worry about what is the base
case of the recurrence.
So the way to solve this
is, in fact, the
way we've seen before.
It's a recursion tree.
So we start with t of n, and
then we replace t of n by the
right hand side, just
by substitution.
So what's always going to be in
the tree as we develop it
is the total amount of work.
So we basically replace it
by f of n plus a copies
of t of n over b.
And then each of those we
replace by a copies so t of n
over b squared.
And so forth, continually
replacing until we get
down to t of 1.
And at the point t of 1, we no
longer can substitute here,
but we know that t
of 1 is order 1.
And now what we do is
add across the rows.
So we get f of n, we get a, f of
n over b, a squared f of n
over b squared, and we keep
going to the height of this,
which we're dividing by the
argument by b each time.
So to get down to 1 is
just log base b of n.
So the number of leaves is,
since this is a regular
[? a area ?]
tree, is a to the height,
which is a to the
log base b of n.
And for each of those,
we're paying t of 1,
which is order 1.
And so now, it turns
out there's
no closed form solution.
If I add up all these
terms, there's
no closed form solution.
But there are three
common situations
that occur in practice.
So yes, this is just n to the
log base b of a, just this
term, not the sum,
just this term.
So three cases have to do with
comparing the number of
leaves, which is times
order 1, with f of n.
So the first case is the case
where n the log base b of a is
bigger than f of n.
So whenever you're given a
recurrence to compute n to the
log base b of a--
I hope this is repeat
for most people.
If not, that's fine,
but hopefully it'll
get you caught up.
n log base b of a, if it's much
bigger than f of n, then
these terms are geometrically
increasing.
And since it's geometrically
increasing, all that matters
is the base case.
In fact, actually, it has to be
not just greater than, it's
got to be greater than by a
polynomial amount, by some n
to the epsilon amount for some
epsilon greater than 0.
So it might be n to the 1/2, it
might be n to the 1/3, it
could be n to the 100th.
But what it can't be is log n,
because log n is less than any
polynomial amount.
So it's got to exceed it by at
least n to the epsilon for
some epsilon.
In that case, it's geometrically
increasing, the
answer is just what's
at the leaves.
So that's case one,
geometrically increasing.
Case two is when things
are actually fairly
equal on every level.
And the general case we'll
look at is when it's
arithmetically increasing.
So in particular, this occurs
when f of n is n to the log
base b of a times log to some
power, n, for some constant k
that's at least 0.
So this is the situation.
If k is equal to 0, it just says
that f of n, the amount
here is exactly the same as
the number of leaves.
And that case, it turns out that
every level has almost
exactly the same amount.
And since there are log n
levels, you tack on an extra
log n for the solution.
In fact, the solution
is one more log.
Turns out that if it's growing
arithmetically with layer, you
basically take on
one extra log.
It's actually like doing
the integral of a as
an arithmetic series.
If you're adding the terms
of, say, i squared,
the result is i cubed.
If you have a summation that
goes from i equals 1 to n of i
squared, the result is
proportional to n cubed.
And similarly, if it's i to any
k, the result is going to
be n to the k plus 1,
and that's basically
what's going on here.
And then the third case is
when it's geometrically
decreasing, when the amount
at the root dominates.
So in this case, if it's much
less than n, and specifically,
f of n is at least n to the
epsilon less than log base b
of a, for some constant epsilon,
it turns out in
addition, you need f of n
to satisfy a regularity
condition, but this regularity
condition is satisfied by all
the normal functions that
we're going to come up.
It's not satisfied by things
like n to the sine n, which
oscillates like crazy.
But it also isn't satisfied by
exponentially growing functions.
But it is satisfied by anything
that's polynomial, or
polynomial times a logarithm,
or what have you.
So generally, we don't
really have to
check this too carefully.
And then the answer there is
just it's order f of n,
because it's geometrically
decreasing, f of n dominates.
So is this review
for everybody?
Pretty much, yeah, yeah, yeah?
You can do this in your head,
because we're going to ask you
to do this in your head
during the lecture?
Yeah, we're all good?
OK, good.
One of the things that students,
when they learn this
in an algorithms class, don't
recognize is that this also
tells you where in your
program, where in your
recursive program, you should
bother to try to eke out
constant factors.
So if you think about it, for
example, in case three here,
it's geometrically decreasing.
Does it make sense to try
to optimize the leaves?
No, because very little
time is spent there.
It makes sense to optimize
what's going on at the root,
and to save anything you
can at the root.
And sometimes, the root in
particular has special
properties that aren't true of
the internal nodes that you
can take advantage of, that you
may not be able to take
advantage of regularly.
But since it's going to be
dominated by the root, trying
to save in the root
makes sense.
Correspondingly, if we're in
case one, in case one, it's
absolutely critical that you
coarsen the recursion, because
all the work is down
at this level.
And so if you want to get
additional performance, you
want to basically move this up
high enough that you can cut
off that constant amount and
get factors two, three,
sometimes more, out
of your code.
So understanding the structure
of the recursion allows you to
figure out where it is that you
should optimize your code.
Of course, with loops,
it's much easier.
Where do you spend your
time with loops to
make code go fast?
The innermost loop, right,
because that's the one that's
executing the most.
The outer loops are not
that important.
This is sort of the
corresponding thing for recursion.
Figure out where the recursion
is spending the time, that's
where you spend time eking
out extra factors.
Here's the cheat sheet.
So if it's n to the log base
b of a minus epsilon, the
answer's n to the
log base b of a.
If it's plus epsilon,
it's f of n.
And if it's n to the log base
b of a times a logarithmic
factor, where this logarithm has
the exponent greater than
or equal to 0, you add a 1.
This is not all of
the situations.
There are situations
which don't occur.
OK, quick quiz.
So t of n equals 4t of
n over 2 plus n.
What's the solution?
n squared, good.
So this is n to the log base b
of a, is n to the log base 2
of 4, which is n squared.
That's much bigger than n.
It's bigger by a factor of n.
Here, the epsilon of 1 would do,
so would an epsilon of 1/2
or an epsilon of 1/4, but
in particular, an
epsilon of 1 would do.
That's case one.
The n squared dominates, so
the answer is n squared.
The basic idea is whichever side
dominates for case one
and case three, that's the
one that is the answer.
Here we go.
What about this one?
n squared log n, because
the two sides are
about the same size.
It's n squared times log to the
0n, tack on the extra log.
How about this one?
n cubed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Master Theorem [INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, the
Master Theorem does not apply
to this one.
It looks like it's case two with
an an exponent of minus
1, but that's bogus because the
exponent of the log must
be greater than or equal to 0.
So instead, this actually has
a solution, so it does not
apply, it actually has the
solution n squared, log log n,
but that's not covered by
the Master Theorem.
You can have an infinite
hierarchy of
narrowing in things.
So if you don't have a solution
to something that
looks like a Master Theorem
type of recurrence, what's
your best strategy
for solving it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: So a
recursion tree can be good,
but actually, the best is the
substitution method, basically
proving it by induction.
And the recursion tree can be
very helpful in giving you a
good guess for what you
think the answer is.
But the most reliable way to
prove any of these things is
using substitution method.
Good enough.
So that was review for,
I hope, most people?
Yeah?
OK, good.
OK, let's talk about parallel
programming.
We're going to start
out with loops.
So last time, we talked about
how the cilk++ runtime system
is based on, essentially,
implementing spawns and syncs,
using the work stealing
algorithm, and we talked about
scheduling and so forth.
We didn't talk about how loops
are implemented, except to
mention that they
were implemented
with divide and conquer.
So here I want to go into the
subtleties of loops, because
probably most programs that
occur in the real world these
days are programs where people
just simply say, make this a
parallel loop.
That's it.
So let's take an example of the
in-place matrix transpose,
where we're basically trying to
flip everything along the
main diagonal.
I've used this figure
before, I think.
So let's just do it not
cache efficiently.
So the cache efficient
algorithm actually
parallelizes beautifully also,
but let's not look at the
cache efficient version, the
divide and conquer version.
Let's look at a looping
version to understand.
And once again here, as I did
before, I'm going to make the
indices for my implementation
run from 0, not 1.
And basically, I have an outer
loop that goes from i equals 1
up to n minus 1, and an inner
loop that goes from j equals 0
up to i minus 1.
And then I do a little
swap in there.
And in here, the outer loop I've
parallelized, the inner
loop is running serially.
So let's take a look at
analyzing this particular
piece of code to understand
what's going on.
So the way this actually gets
implemented is as follows.
So here's the code
on the left.
What actually happens in the
cilk++ compiler is it converts
it into recursion, divide
and conquer recursion.
So what it does is it has a
range from low to high, is
sort of the common case.
We're going to call it on from 1
to n minus 1, because that's
the indexes that I've given
to the cilk_for loop.
And what we do is, if I have
a region to do divide and
conquer on, a set of values
for i, I basically
divide that in half.
And then I recursively execute
the first half, and then the
second half, and
then cilk_sync.
So the two sides are going
off in parallel.
And then if I am at the base,
then I go through the inner
loop and do the swap of the
values in the inner loop.
So the outer loop is the one
that's the parallel loop.
That one we're doing divide
and conquer on.
So we basically recursively
spawn the first half, execute
the second, and then each of
those recursively does the
same thing until all the
iterations have been done.
Any questions about
how that operates?
So this is the way all the
parallel loops are done, is
basically this strategy.
Now here, I mention that this
is in fact what happens is
this test here is actually
coarsened.
So we don't want to go all the
way to n equals 1, because
then we'll have this recursion
call overhead every
time we do a call.
So in fact, what happens is you
go down to some grain size
of some number of iterations,
and at that number of
iterations, it then just runs
through it as an ordinary
serial four loop, in order not
to pay the function call
overhead all the way down.
We're going to look exactly
at that issue.
So if I take a look at it from
using the DAG model that I
introduced last time, remember
that the rectangles here kind
of count as activation
frames, stack
frames on the call stack.
And the circles here are
strands, which are sequences
of serial code.
And so what's happening here
is essentially, I'm running
the code that divides
it into two parts,
and I spawn one part.
Then this guy spawns the other
and waits for the return, and
then these guys come back.
And then I keep doing that
recursively, and then when I
get to the bottom, I then run
through the innermost loop,
which starts out with just one
element to do, two, three.
And so the number
of elements--
for example, in this case where
I've done eight, I go
through eight elements at the
bottom here if this were an
eight by eight matrix that
I was transposing.
So there's more work in these
guys than there is over here.
So it's not something you just
can map onto processors in
some naive fashion.
It does take some load
balancing to
parallelize this loop.
Any questions about what's
going on here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is it that
it's one, two,
three, four, up to eight?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Take a look.
The inner loop goes
from j to i.
So this guy just does one
iteration of the inner loop,
this guy does two, this guy does
three, all the way up to
this guy doing eight iterations,
if it were an
eight by eight matrix.
And in general, if it's n by
n, it's going from one to n
work up here, but only
one work down here.
Because I'm basically iterating
through a triangular
iteration space to swap the
matrix, and this is basically
swapping row by row.
Questions?
Is that good?
Everybody see what's going on?
So now let's take a look
and let's analyze this
for work and span.
So what is the work of this
in terms of n, if I
have an n by n matrix?
What's the work?
The work is the ordinary serial
running time, right?
It's n squared.
Good.
So basically, it's order n
squared, because these guys
are all adding up.
This is an arithmetic sequence
up to n, and so the total
amount in here is
order n squared.
What about this part up here?
How much does that
cost us for work?
How much is in the control
overhead of
doing that outer loop?
So asymptotically, how
much is in here?
The total is going
to be n squared.
That I guarantee you.
But what's going on up here?
How do I count that up?
AUDIENCE: I'm assuming that each
[? strain ?] is going to
be constant time?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, well
in this case, it is constant
time, for these up here, because
what am I doing?
All I'm doing is the recursion
code where I divide the range
and then spawn off two things.
That takes me only a constant
amount of manipulation to be
able to do that.
So this is all order n.
Total of order n here.
The reason is because
in some sense, there
are n leaves here.
And if you have a full binary
tree, meaning every child is
either a leaf or has two
children, then the number of
the internal nodes of the
tree is one less than
the number of leaves.
So that's a basic property of
trees, that the number of the
internal nodes here is going to
be n minus 1, in this case.
In particular, we have 7 here.
Is that good?
So this part doesn't contribute
significantly to the work.
Just this part contributes
to the work.
Is that good?
What about the span for this?
What's the span?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's not log
n, but your heads are in
the right place.
AUDIENCE: The longest path
is going [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Which is the
longest path going to be
here, starting here and ending
there, which way do we go?
AUDIENCE: Go all the way down.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Which way?
AUDIENCE: To the right.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Down to
the right, over, down
through this guy.
How big is this guy?
n.
Go back up this way.
So how much is in this
part going down?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Going
down and up is log
n, but this is n.
Good.
So it's basically order n plus
order log n, order n down here
plus order log n up and
down, that's order n.
So the parallelism is the ratio
of those two things,
which is order n.
So that's got good
parallelism.
And so if you imagine doing
this in a large number
processors, very easy to get
sort of your benchmark of
maybe 10 times more parallelism
than the number of
processors that you're
running on.
Everybody follow this?
Good.
So the span of the loop control
is order log n.
And in general, when you have a
four loop with n iterations,
the loop control itself is going
to have log n is going
to have to be added to the
span every time you hit a
loop, log of whatever the
number of iterations is.
And then we have the maximum
span of the body.
Well, the worst case for this
thing in the body is when it's
doing the whole thing, because
whenever we're looking at
spans, we're always looking
what's the maximum of things
that are operating
in parallel.
Everybody good?
Questions?
Great.
So now let's do something
a little more parallel.
Let's make both loops
be parallel.
So here we have a cilk_for loop
here, and then another
cilk_for loop on the interior.
And let's see what
we get here.
So what's the work for this?
AUDIENCE: n squared.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, n squared.
That's not going to change.
What's the span?
AUDIENCE: log n.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, log n.
So it's log n because the span
of the outer control loop is
going to add log n.
The max span of the inner
control loop, well, it's going
from log of 1 up to log of i,
but the maximums of those is
going to be proportional
to log n
because it's not regular.
And the span of the body now
is going to be order 1.
And so we add the logs because
those things are in series.
We don't multiply them.
What we're doing is
we're looking at,
what's the worst case?
The worst case is I have to do
the control for this, plus the
control for this, plus the worst
iteration here, which in
this case is just order one.
So the total is order log n.
That can be confusing for
people, why it is that we add
here rather than multiply
or do something else.
So let me pause here
for some questions
if people have questions.
Everybody with us?
Anybody want clarification or
make a point that would lead
to clarification?
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: If you were going to
draw a tree like the previous
slide, what would
it look like?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Let's see.
I had wanted to do that and
it got out of control.
So what it would look like is if
we go back to the previous
slide, it basically would look
like this, except where each
one of these guys is replaced by
a tree that looks like this
with as many leaves as the
number here indicates.
So once again, this would be the
one with the longest span
because this would be log
of the largest number.
But basically, each one of these
would be a tree that
came from this.
Is that clear?
That's a great question.
Anybody else have
as illuminating
questions as those?
Everybody understand that
explanation, what the tree
would look like?
OK, good.
Get
So the parallelism here is
n squared over log n.
Now it's tempting, when you do
parallel programming, to say
therefore, this is better
parallel code.
And the reason is, well, it does
asymptotically have more
parallelism.
But generally when you're
programming, you're not trying
to get the most parallelism.
What you're trying to do is get
sufficient parallelism.
So if n is sufficiently large,
it's going to be way more--
if n is a million--
which is typical problem size
for a loop, for example, for a
big loop, or even if it's a
few thousand or whatever--
it may be just fine to have
parallelism on the order of
1,000, which is what the
first one gives you.
So 1,000 iterations is generally
a small number of
iterations.
So 1,000 by 1,000 matrix
is going to generate
parallelism of 1,000.
Here, we're going to get a
parallelism of 1 million
divided by about 20, log of
10 or 20, so like 100,000.
But if I have 1,000 by 1,000
matrix, the difference between
having parallelism of 1,000 and
parallelism of 100,000,
when I'm running on 100 cores,
let's say, it doesn't matter.
Up to 100 cores, it
doesn't matter.
And in fact, running this on
100 cores, that's really a
tiny problem compared to
the amount of memory
you're going to get.
1,000 by 1,000 matrix is tiny
when it comes to the size of
memory that you're going to have
access to and so forth.
So for big problems and so forth
you really want to look
at this and say, of things that
have ample parallelism,
which ones really are going to
give me the best bang for the
buck for reasonable
machine sizes?
That's different from
things like work or
serial running time.
Usually less running
time is better,
and it's always better.
But here parallelism--
yes, it's good to minimize your
span, but you don't have
to minimize it extremely.
You just have to get it small
enough, whereas the work term,
that you really want to
minimize, because that's what
you're going to have to
do, even in a serial
implementation.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So are you
suggesting that the
other code was OK?
CHARLES LEISERSON: We're going
to look a little bit closer at
the issue of overheads.
We're now going to take a look
at what's the difference
between these two codes?
We'll come back to
that in a minute.
The way I want to do it is take
a look at the issue of
overheads with a simpler
example, where we can see
what's really going on.
So here, what I've done is
I've got a loop that is
basically just doing
vector addition.
It's adding for i equals
0 to n minus 1, add b
of i into a of i.
Pretty simple code, and we
want to make that be a
parallel loop.
So I get a recursion tree that
looks like this, where I have
constant work at every
step there.
And of course, the
work is order n,
because I've got n leaves.
And the number of internal
nodes, the control, is all
constant size strands there.
So this is all just
order n for work.
And the span is basically log
n, as we've seen, by going
down one of these paths,
for example.
And so the parallelism for this
is order n over log n.
So a very simple problem.
But now let's take a look more
closely at the overheads here.
So the problem is that
this work term
contains substantial overhead.
In other words, if I really was
doing that, if I hadn't
coarsened the recursion at all
in the implementation of
cilk_for, if the developers
hadn't done that, then I've
got a function call, I've got
n function calls here for
doing a single addition of
values at the leaves.
I've got n minus one of these
guys, that's approximately n,
and I've got n of these guys.
And which are bigger, these
guys or these guys?
These guys are way bigger.
They've got a function
call in there.
This guy right here
just has what?
One floating point addition.
And so if I really was doing my
divide and conquer down to
a single element, this would be
way slower on one processor
than if I just ran it
with a for loop.
Because if I do a for loop, it's
just going to go through,
and the overhead it has is
incrementing i and testing for
termination.
That's it.
And of course, that's a
predictable branch, because it
almost never terminates until it
actually terminates, and so
that's exactly the sort of thing
that's going to have a
really, really tight loop with
very few instructions.
But in the parallel
implementation, there's going
to be this function call
overhead everywhere.
And so therefore, this cilk_for
loop in principle
would not be as efficient.
It actually is, but we're going
to explain why it is,
what goes on in the runtime
system, to understand that.
So here's the idea, and you can
control this with a pragma.
So a pragma is a statement
to the compiler
that gives it a hint.
And here, the pragma says, you
can name a grain size and give
it a value of g.
And what that says is rather
than just doing one element
when you get down to the bottom
here, do g elements in
a for loop when you get
down to the bottom.
And that way, you halt the
recursion earlier.
You have fewer of these
internal nodes.
And if you make the grain size
sufficiently large, the cost
of the recursion at the top
you won't be able to see.
So let's analyze what happens
when we do this.
So we can understand this
vis a vis this equation.
So the idea here is, if I look
at my work, imagine that t
iter is the time for iteration
of one iteration of the loop,
basic time for one iteration
of the loop.
So the amount of work that I
have to do is n times the time
for the iterations
of the loop.
And then depending upon my grain
size, I've got to do
things having to do with the
internal nodes, and there's
basically going to be n over g
of those, times the time for a
spawn, which is I'm saying is
the time to execute one of
these things.
So if these are batched into
groups of g, then there are n
over g such leaves.
There's a minus 1 in here,
but it doesn't matter.
It's basically n over
g times the time for
the internal nodes.
So everybody see where
I'm getting this?
So I'm trying to account for
the constants in the
implementation.
People follow where
I'm getting this?
Ask questions.
I see a couple of people who are
sort of going, not sure I
understand.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The constants
[INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
So basically, the constants are
these t iter and t spawn.
So t spawn is the time to
execute all that mess.
t iter is the time to execute
one iteration within here.
I'm doing, in this
case, g of them.
So I have n over g leaves, but
each one is doing g, so it's n
over g times g, which is a total
of n iterations, which
makes sense.
I should be doing n
iterations if I'm
adding two vectors here.
So that's accounting for all
the work in these guys.
Then in addition, I've got all
of the work for all the
spawning, which is n over
g times t spawn.
And as I say, you can play with
this yourself, play with
grain size yourself, by just
sticking in different grain
size directives.
Otherwise it turns out that the
cilk runtime system will
pick what it deems to be
a good grain size.
And it usually does a good
job, except sometimes.
And that's why there's
a parameter here.
So if there's a parameter
there, you
can get rid of that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the pragma
something that is enforced, or
is it something that
says, hey--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It's a hint.
AUDIENCE: It's a hint.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yes, it's a hint.
In other words, compiler
could ignore it.
[?
AUDIENCE: The compiler is ?]
going to be like, oh, that's
the total [INAUDIBLE]
constant.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's supposed
to be something that
gives a hint for performance
reasons but does not affect
the correctness of
the program.
So the program is going to
be doing the same thing
regardless.
The question is, here's a hint
to the compiler and the
runtime system.
And so then it's picked at--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: My question is, so
there's these cases where you
say that the runtime system
fails to find an appropriate
value for that [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, basically, chooses
one that's not as good.
If you put a pragma on it, will
the runtime system choose
the one that you give it,
or still choose--
CHARLES LEISERSON: No,
if you give it, the
runtime system will--
in the current implementation,
it always picks whatever you
say is here.
And that can be an expression.
You can evaluate something
there.
It's not just a constant.
It could be maximum of
this and that times
whatever, et cetera.
Is that good?
So this is a description
of the work.
Now let's get a description
with the constants
again of the span.
So what is going to be the
constants for the span?
Well, I'm executing this part
in here now serially.
So for the span part, we're
basically going to go down on
one of these paths and back up
I'm not sure which one, but
they're basically all
fairly symmetric.
But then when I get
to the leaf, I'm
executing the leaf serially.
So I'm going to have whatever
the cost is, g times the time
per iteration, is going to be
executed serially, plus now
log of n over g--
n over g is the number of
things I have here--
times the cost of the
spawn, basically.
Does that make sense?
So the idea is, what do we want
to have here if I want a
good parallel code?
We would like the work to
be as small as possible.
How do I make the work small?
How can I set g to make
the work small?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Make g--
AUDIENCE: Square root of n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Well,
make g big or little?
If you want this term to be
small, you want g to be big.
But we also want to have
a lot of parallelism.
So I want this term
to be what?
Small, which means I need
to make g what?
Well, we got an n over g here,
but it's in a log.
It's minus log.
So really, to get this small,
I want g to be small.
So I have tension, trade off.
I have trade off.
So let's analyze this
a little bit.
Essentially, if I look at this,
I want g to be bigger--
from this one I want
g to be small.
But here, what I would like is
to make it so that this term
dominates this term.
If the first term here dominates
the second term,
then the work is going to be
the same as if I did an
ordinary for loop to within
a few percent.
So therefore, I want t span
over t iter, if I take the
ratio of these things, I want
g to be bigger than the time
to spawn divided by the
time to iterate.
If I get it much bigger than
that, then this term will be
much bigger than that term
and I don't have to
worry about this term.
So I want it to be much bigger,
but I want to be as
small as possible.
There's no point in making it
much bigger than that which
causes this term to essentially
be wiped out.
People follow that?
So basically, the idea is we
pick a grain size that's large
but not too large, is what you
generally want to do, so that
you have enough parallelism,
but you don't.
The way that the runtime system
does it is it has a
somewhat complicated heuristic,
but it actually
looks to see how many processors
you're running on.
And it uses a heuristic that
says, let's make sure there's
at least parallelism 10 times
more than the number of
processors.
But there's no point in having
more iterations than like 500
or something, because at 500
iterations, you can't see the
spawn overhead regardless.
So basically, it uses a formula
kind of that nature to
pick this automatically.
But you're free to pick
this yourself.
But you can see the point is
that although it's doing
divide and conquer, you do this
issue of coarsening and
you do want to make sure that
you have enough work to do in
any of the leaves of
the computation.
And as I say, usually
it'll guess right.
But if you have trouble with
that, you have a parameter you
can play with.
Let's take a look at another
implementation just to try to
understand this issue.
Suppose I'm going to
do a vector add.
So here I have a vector add
of two arrays, where I'm
basically saying ai gets the
value of b added into it.
That's kind of the code
we had before.
But now, what I want to do is
I'm going to implement a
vector add using cilk spawn.
So rather than using a cilk_for
loop, I'm going to
parallelize this loop by
hand using cilk spawn.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to say for j equals 0 up
to-- and I'm going to
jump by whatever my
grain size is here--
and spawn off the addition of
things of size, essentially,
g, unless I get close to
the end of the array.
But basically, I'm always
spawning off the next g
iterations to do that
in parallel.
And then I sync all
these spawns.
So everybody understand
the code?
I see nods.
I want to see everybody nod,
actually, when I do this.
Otherwise what happens is I see
three people nod, and I
assume that people
are nodding.
Because if you don't do it, you
can shake your head, and I
promise none of your friends
will see that you're
shaking your head.
And since the TAs are doing the
grading and they're facing
this way, they won't
see either.
And so it's perfectly safe to
let me know, and that way I
can make sure you understand.
So everybody understand
what this does?
OK, so I see a few more.
No.
OK, question?
Do you have a question, or
should I just explain again?
So this is basically doing a
vector add of b into a, of n
iterations here.
And we're going to call it here,
when I do a vector add,
of basically g iterations.
So what it's doing is it's going
to take my array of size
n, bust it into chunks of size
g, and spawn off the first
one, spawn off the second one,
spawn off the third one, each
one to do g iterations.
That make sense?
We'll see it.
So here's sort of the
instruction stream
for the code here.
So basically, it says here is
one, we spawn off something of
size g, then we go on, we spawn
off something else of
size g, et cetera.
We keep going up there until
we hit the cilk sync.
That make sense?
Each of these is doing a vector
add of size g using
this serial routine.
So let's analyze this to
understand the efficiency of
this type of looping
structure.
So let's assume for this
analysis that g equals 1, to
make it easy, so we don't
have to worry about it.
So we're simply spawning off
one thing here, one thing
here, one iteration here,
all the way to the end.
So what is the work for this, if
I spawn off things of size
one, asymptotic work?
It's order n, because I've got
n leaves, and I've got n guys
that I'm spawning off.
So it's order n.
What's the span?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, it's
also order n, because the
critical path goes something
like brrrup, brrrup, brrrup.
That's order n length.
It's not this, because
that's only order
one length, all those.
The longest path is order n.
So that says the parallelism
is order one.
Conclusion, at least with grain
size one, this is a
really bad way to implement
a parallel loop.
However, I guarantee, it may
not be the people in this
room, but some fraction of
students in this class will
write this rather than
doing a cilk for.
Bad idea.
Generally, bad idea.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Do you think you could
find a constant factor,
not just [INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Well here,
actually, with grain size one,
this is really bad, because
I've got this overhead of
doing a spawn, and then I'm
only doing one iteration.
So the ideal thing would be that
I really am only paying
for the leaves, and the internal
nodes, I don't have
to pay anything for.
Yeah, Eric?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't there
be a sort of keyword
in the b add too?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
In the where?
AUDIENCE: In the b add?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No,
that's serial.
That's a serial code.
AUDIENCE: No, but if you were
going to call it with cilk
spawn, don't you have
to declare it cilk?
Is that not the case?
CHARLES LEISERSON: No.
AUDIENCE: Never mind.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: If g is [INAUDIBLE],
isn't that good enough?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
so let's take a look.
That's actually the
next slide.
This is basically, this we
call puny parallelism.
We don't like puny
parallelism.
It doesn't have to
be spectacular.
It has to be good enough.
And this is not good enough
for most applications.
So here's another
implementation.
Here's another way
of doing it.
Now let's analyze it where
we have control over g.
So we'll analyze it in terms
of g, and then see whether
there's a setting for which
this make sense.
So if I analyze it in terms of
g, now I have to do a little
bit more careful
analysis here.
How much work do I have here
in terms of n and g?
AUDIENCE: It's the same.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
the work is still
asymptotically order n.
Because I always have n work
in the leaves, even if I do
more iterations here.
What increasing g does is
it shrinks this, right?
It shrinks this.
The span for this is what?
So I heard somebody say it.
n over g plus g.
And it corresponds
to this path.
So this is the n over
g part up here, and
this is the plus g.
So what we want to do to
minimize this, is we can
minimize this.
This has the smallest value
when these two terms are
equal, which you can either know
as a basic fact of the
summation of these kinds of
things, or you could take
derivatives and so forth.
Or you can just eyeball it and
say, gee, if g is bigger than
square root of n, then this is
going to be the dominant, and
if g is smaller than square root
of n, then this is going
to be dominant.
And so when they're equal, that
sounds like about when it
should be the smallest,
which is true.
So we pick it to be about
square root of n, to
minimize the span.
Since g, I don't have anything
to minimize here.
So pick it around square root of
n, then the span is around
square root of n.
And so then the parallelism
is order square root of n.
So that's pretty good.
So that's not bad.
So for something that's a big
array, array of size 1
million, parallelism
might be 1,000.
That might be just hunky dory.
Question.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: I don't see where--
CHARLES LEISERSON: We've
picked g to be equal to
square root of n.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] plus
n over g, plus g.
I don't see where [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: You don't
see where this g came from?
This g comes from, because I'm
doing g iterations here.
So remember that these
are now of size g.
I'm doing g iterations
in each leaf here, if
I set g to be large.
So I'm doing n over g pieces
here, plus g iterations in my
[INAUDIBLE].
Is that clear?
So the n over g is this part.
This size here, this
is not one.
This has g iterations in it.
So the total span is
g plus n over g.
Any other questions
about this?
So basically, I get order
square root of n.
And so this is not necessarily a
bad way of doing it, but the
cilk for is a far more reliable
way of making sure
that you get the parallelism
than spawning
things off one by one.
One of the things, by the way,
in this, I've seen people
write code where their first
instinct is to write something
like this, where this that
they're spawning off is only
constant time.
And they say, gee, I spawned
off n things.
That's really parallel.
When in fact, their parallelism
is order one.
So it's really seductive to
think that you can get
parallelism by this,
[? right. ?]
It's much better to do divide
and conquer, and cilk for does
that for you automatically.
If you're going to do it by
hand, sometimes you do want to
do it by hand, then you probably
want to think more
about divide and conquer to
generate parallelism, because
you'll have a small span,
than doing many
things one at a time.
So here's some tips
for performance.
So you want to minimize the
span, so the parallelism is
the work over the span.
So you want to minimize the span
to maximize parallelism.
And in general, you should try
to generate something like 10
times more parallelism than
processors, if you want to get
near perfect linear speed-up.
In other words, a parallel
slackness of 10 or better is
usually adequate.
If you can get more, you're now
talking that you can get
more performance, but now you're
getting performance
increases in the range of
5% or so, 5% to 10%,
something like that.
Second thing is if you have
plenty of parallelism, try to
trade some of it off to
reduce work overhead.
So this is a general case.
This is what actually goes on
underneath in the cilk++
runtime system, is they are
trying to do this themselves.
But you in your own code can
play exactly the same game.
Whenever you have a problem and
it says, whoa, look at all
this parallelism, think about
ways that you could reduce the
parallelism and get something
back in the efficiency of the
work term, because the
performance in the end is
going to be something like t1
over p plus t infinity.
If t infinity is small, it's
like t1 over p, and so
anything you save in the t1 term
is saving you overall.
It's going to be a savings
for you overall.
Use divide and conquer recursion
on parallel loops
rather than sprawling one small
thing after another.
In other words, do this
not this, generally.
And here's some more tips.
Another thing that can happen
that we looked at here was
make sure that the amount
of work you're doing is
reasonably large compared
to the number of spawns.
You could also say this is true
when you do recursion for
function calls.
Make sure if you're just in
serial programming, you always
want to make sure that the
amount of work you're doing is
small compared to the number of
function calls are doing if
you can, and that'll make
things go faster.
So same thing here, you want to
have a lot of work compared
to the total number of
spawns that you're
doing in your program.
So spawns, by the way, in this
system, are about three or
four times the cost of
a function call.
They're sort of the same order
of magnitude as a function
call, a little bit heavier
than a function call.
So you can spawn pretty readily,
as long as the total
number of spawns you're doing
isn't dominating your work.
Generally parallelize outer
loops as opposed to inner
loops if you're forced
to make a choice.
So it's always better to have
an outer loop that runs in
parallel rather than an inner
loop that runs in parallel,
because when you do an inner
you've got a lot of overhead
to overcome.
But in an outer loop, you've got
all of the inner loop to
amortize against the cost of the
spawns that are being used
to parallelize the outer loop.
So you'll do many fewer spawns
in the implementation.
Watch out for scheduling
overheads.
So if you do something
like this--
so here we're paralyzing an
inner loop rather than an
outer loop.
Now this turns out, it doesn't
matter which order we're going
in or whatever.
It's generally not desirable to
do this because I'm paying
scheduling overhead n times
through this loop, whereas
here, I pay for scheduling
overhead just twice.
So is generally better, if I
have n pieces of work to do,
rather than, in this case,
parallelizing--
let me slow down here.
So let's look at what
this code does.
This says, go for
two iterations.
Do something for which
it is going to take n
iterations for j.
So two iterations for i,
n iterations for j.
If you look at the parallelism
of this, what is the
parallelism of this assuming
that f is constant time?
What's the parallelism
of this code?
Two.
The parallelism of two, because
I've got two things on
the outer loop here,
and then each is n.
So my span is essentially n.
My work is like 2n, something
like that.
So it's got a parallelism
of that, too.
What's the parallelism
of this code?
What's the parallelism?
It's not n, because I'm
basically going through this
serially, the outer
loop serially.
What's the theoretical
parallelism of this?
So for each iteration here,
the parallelism is two.
No, not n.
It can't be n, because I'm
basically only parallelizing
two things, and I'm doing
them serially.
The outer loop is going serially
through the code and
it's spawning off two things,
two things, two things, two
things, two things.
And waiting for them to be done,
two things, wait for it
to be done, two things, wait
for it to be done.
So the parallelism is two.
These have the same
parallelism.
However if you run this, this
one will give you a speedup of
two on two cores, very
close to it.
Because there's the scheduling
overhead here, you've only
paid once for the scheduling
overhead, and then you're
doing a whole bunch of stuff.
So remember, to schedule it,
it's got to be migrated, it's
got to be moved to another
processor, et cetera.
This one, it's not even worth
it probably to steal each of
these individual things.
You're spawning off things that
are so small, this may
even have parallelism that's
less than 1 in practice.
And if you look at the cilkview
tool, this will show
you a high burden parallelism.
Because the cilkview tool, the
burden parallelism tells you
what the overhead is from
scheduling, as well as what
the actual parallelism is.
And it recognizes that
oh, gee whiz.
This thing really
has very small--
there's almost no
work in here.
So you're trying to parallelize
something where
the work is so small, it's not
even worth migrating it to
take advantage of it.
So those are some tips.
Now let's go through and analyze
a bunch of algorithms
reasonably quickly.
We'll start with matrix
multiplication.
People seen this
problem before?
Here's the matrix multiplication
problem.
And let's assume for
simplicity that n
is a power of 2.
So basically, let's start out
with just our looping version.
In fact, this isn't even a very
good looping version,
because I've got the order of
the loops wrong, I think.
But it is just illustrative.
Basically let's parallelize
the outer two loops.
I can't parallelize
the inner loop.
Why not?
What happens if I tried to
parallelize the inner loop
with a cilk_for in this
implementation?
Why can't I just put
a cilk_for there?
Yes, somebody said it.
AUDIENCE: It does that in cij.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, we
get a race condition.
We have more than two things in
parallel trying to update
the same cij, and we'll
have a race condition.
So always run cilkview to
tell your performance.
But always, always, run cilk
screen to tell whether or not
you've got races in your code.
So yeah, you'll have a race
condition if you try to
naively parallelize
the loop here.
So the work of this is what?
It's order n cubed, just three
nested loops each going to n.
What's the span of this?
It's order n, because it's log
n for this loop, log n for
this loop, plus the maximum
of this, well, that's n.
Log n plus log n plus
n is order n.
So order n span, which says
parallelism is order n squared.
So for 1,000 by 1,000 matrices,
the parallelism is
on the order of a million.
Wow.
That's great.
However, it's on the order of
a million, but as we know,
this doesn't use cache
very effectively.
So one of the nice things about
doing divide and conquer
is, as you know, that's a
really good way to take
advantage of caching.
And this works in
parallel, too.
In particular because whenever
you have sufficient
parallelism, these processors
are executing the code just as
if they were executing
serial code.
So you get all the same cache
locality you would get in the
serial code in the parallel
code, except for the times
that you're actually
migrating work.
And if you have sufficient
parallelism,
that isn't too often.
So let's take a look at
recursive divide and conquer
multiplication.
So we're familiar
with this, too.
So this is eight multiplications
of n over 2 by
2 matrices, and one addition
of n by n matrix.
So here's a code using a
little bit of C++ism.
So I've made the type
a variable t.
So we're going to do matrix
multiplication of an array, a,
the result is going to go
in c, and we're going to
basically have a and b,
and we're going to add
the result into c.
We have n, which is the side
of the submatrix that we're
working on, and we're also going
to have an n size, which
is the length of the row
in the original matrix.
So remember when we do matrix
things, if I take a submatrix,
it's not contiguous in memory.
So I have to know the row size
of the matrix that I'm in in
order to be able to calculate
what the elements are.
So the way it's going to work
is I'm going to assign this
temporary d, by using
the new--
which is basically memory
allocation C++--
array of size n by n.
And what we're going to do is
then do four of the recursive
multiplications, these guys
here, into the elements of c,
and then four of them also into
d using the temporary.
And then we're going to sync,
after we get all that parallel
work done, and then we're going
to add d into c, and
then we'll delete d, because
we allocated it up here.
Everybody understand the code?
So we're doing this,
it's just we're
going to do it in parallel.
Good?
Questions?
OK.
So this is the row length of the
matrices so that I can do
the base cases, and in
particular, partition the
matrices effectively.
I haven't shown that code.
And of course, the base case,
normally, we would want to
coarsen for efficiency.
I would want to go down to
something like maybe a eight
by eight or 16 by 16 matrix,
and at that point switch to
something that's going to use
the processor pipeline better.
The base cases, once again, I
want to emphasize this because
a couple people on the quiz
misunderstood this.
The reason you coarsen has
nothing to do with caches.
The reason you coarsen is to
overcome the overhead of the
function calls, and the
coarsening is generally chosen
independent of what the size
of the caches are.
It's not a parameter that has
to be tuned to cache size.
It's a parameter that has to
be tuned to function call,
versus ALU instructions, and
what that balance is.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I understand
that's true, but I thought--
I mean, maybe I
[? heard the call ?] wrong,
but I thought we wanted, in
general, in terms of caching,
that you would choose it somehow
so that all of the
data that you have would
somehow fit--
CHARLES LEISERSON: That's what
the divide and conquer does
automatically.
The divide and conquer keeps
halving it until it fits in
whatever size cache you have.
And in fact, we have
three caches on the
machines we're using.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but I'm saying
if your coarsened constant is
too big, that's not
going to happen.
CHARLES LEISERSON: If the
coarsened constant is too big,
that's not going to happen.
But generally, the caches are
much bigger than what you need
to do to amortize the cost.
But you're right, that
is an assumption.
The caches are generally much
bigger than the size that you
need in order to overcome
function call overhead.
Function call overhead
is not that high.
OK?
Good.
I'm glad I raised that
issue again.
And so we're going to determine
the submatrices by
index calculation.
And then we have to implement
this parallel add, and that
I'm going to do just with a
doubly nested for loop to add
the things.
There's no cache behavior I can
really take advantage of
here except for spatial
locality.
There's no temporal locality
because I'm just adding two
matrices once, so there's no
real temporal locality that
I'll get out of it.
And here, I've actually
done the index
calculations by hand.
So let's analyze this.
So to analyze the multiplication
program, I have
to start by analyzing the
addition program.
So this should be, I think,
fairly straightforward.
What's the work for adding
two n by n matrices here?
n squared, good, just
doubly nested loop.
What's the span?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, here
it's log n, very good.
Because I've got log n plus
log n plus order one.
I'm not going to analyze the
parallelism, because I really
don't care about the parallelism
of the addition.
I really care about the
parallelism of the matrix
multiplication.
But we'll plug those
values in now.
What is the work of the
matrix multiplication?
Well for this, what we want to
do is get a recurrence that we
can then solve.
So what's the recurrence
that we want to get
for m of 1 of n?
Yeah, it's going to be 8m
sub 1 of n over 2, that
corresponds to these things,
plus some constant stuff, plus
the work of the addition.
Does that make sense?
We analyze the work
of the addition.
What's the work of
the addition?
Order n squared.
So that's going to dominate
that constant
there, so we get 8.
And what's the solution
to this?
Back to Master Theorem.
Now we're going to start pulling
out the Master Theorem
multiple times per slide for
the rest of the lecture.
n cubed, because we have
log base 2 of 8.
That's n cubed compared
with n squared.
So we get a solution
which is n cubed--
Case 3 of the Master Theorem.
So that's good.
The work we're doing is the
same asymptotic work we're
doing for the triply
nested loop.
Now let's take a look
at the span.
So what's the span for this?
So once again, we want
a recurrence.
What's the recurrence
look like?
So the span of this is going
to be the span of--
it's going to be the
sum of some things.
But the key observation is that
it's going to be-- we
want the maximum
of these guys.
So we're going to basically
have the allocation as
constant time, we have the
maximum of these, which is m
of infinity of n over
2, and then we have
the span of the add.
So we get this recurrence.
m infinity sub n over 2, because
we have only to worry
about the worst of these guys.
The worst of them is--
they're all symmetric, so
it's basically the same.
We have a of n, and then there's
a constant amount of
other overhead here.
Any questions about where I
pulled that out of, why that's
the recurrence?
So this is the addition, the
span of the addition of this
guy that we analyzed already.
What is the span of
the addition?
What did we decide that was?
log n.
So basically, that dominates
the order one.
So we get this term, and what's
the solution of this
recurrence?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: What
case is this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
log n squared.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes,
it's log squared n.
So basically, it's case two.
So if I do n to the log base b
of a, that's n to the log base
2 of 1, that's just 1.
And so this is basically a
logarithmic factor times the
1, so we add an extra log.
We get log squared n.
That's just Master Theorem
plugging in.
So here, the span is order
log squared n.
And so we have the work of n
cubed, the span of log squared
n, so the parallelism is the
ratio, which is n cubed over
log squared n.
Not too bad for a 1,000
by 1,000 matrices, the
parallelism is about
10 million.
Plenty of parallelism.
So let's use the fact that we
have plenty of parallelism to
say, let's get rid of some of
that parallelism and put it
back into making our code
more efficient.
So in particular, this code
uses an extra temporary d,
which it allocates here
and it deletes here.
And generally, there's a good
rule that says, if you use
more storage you're going to use
more time, because you're
going to have to look at that
storage, it's going to take up
space in your cache,
and it's generally
going to make you slower.
So things that use less storage
are generally faster.
Not always the case, sometimes
there's a trade off.
But often it's the case, use
more storage, it runs slower.
So let's get rid of this guy.
How do we get rid of this guy?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: You're going
to do this serially,
you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you do those
serially in add.
CHARLES LEISERSON: If you do
this serially in add, it turns
out if you do that, you're going
to be in trouble because
you're going to not have
very much parallelism,
unfortunately.
Actually, analyzing exactly what
the parallelism is there
is actually pretty good.
It's a good puzzle.
Maybe we'll do that on the quiz,
the take home problem
set we're calling
it now, right?
We're going to have a take home
problem set, maybe that's
a good one.
Yeah, so the idea is,
you can sync.
And in particular, why not
compute these, then sync, and
then compute these, adding their
results into the places
where we added these in?
So it's making the program
more serial, because I'm
putting in a sync.
That shouldn't have an impact on
the work, but it will have
an impact on the span.
So we're going to trade it off,
and the way we'll do that
is by putting essentially
a sync in the middle.
And since they're adding it in,
I don't even have we call
the addition routine, because
it's just going to
add it in in place.
So I spawn off these four guys,
putting their results
into c, then I spawn off these
four guys, and they add their
results into c.
Is that clear what
the code is?
So let's analyze this.
So the work for this
is order n cubed.
It's the same as anything else,
we can come up with a
recurrence, slightly different
from before because I only
have an order one there, but
it doesn't really matter.
The answer is order n cubed.
The span, now this gets
a little trickier.
What's the recurrence
of the span?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Twice the span
of m of n over 2.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Twice
the span of m of n
over 2, that's right.
So basically, we have the
maximum of these guys, the
maximum of these guys, and
then this is making those
things be in series.
So things that are in parallel
I take the max, if it's in
series, I have to add them.
So I end up with 2m infinity
of n over 2 plus order one.
Does that make sense?
OK, good.
So let's solve that
recurrence.
What's the answer to that one?
That's order in.
Which case is it?
I never know what
the cases are.
I know two, but one and
three, it's like--
they're the same thing, it's
just which side it's in, so I
never remember what
the number is.
But anyway, case one, yes.
Case one.
It's the one where this thing is
bigger, so that's order n.
Good.
So then the work is n cubed,
the span is order n, the
parallelism is order
n squared.
So for 1,000 by 1,000 matrices,
I get parallelism on
the order of a million, instead
of before, I had
parallelism on the order
of 10 million.
So this turns out way better
code than the previous one
because it avoids the temporary
and therefore runs,
you get a constant factor
improvement for that, and it's
still, on 12 cores, it's going
to run pretty fast.
And in practice, this is a
much better way to do it.
The actual best code that
I know for doing this
essentially does divide and
conquer in only one
dimension at a time.
So basically, it looks to see
what's the long dimension, and
whatever the long dimension is,
it slices it in half and
then recurses, and just does
that as a binary thing.
And it basically is the
same work, et cetera.
It's a little bit more
tricky to analyze.
Let me quick do merge sort.
So you know merge sort.
There's merging two sorted
arrays, we saw this before.
If I spend all this time doing
animations, I might as well
get my mileage out of it.
There we go.
So you merge, that's basically
what this code does.
Order n time to merge.
So here's merge sort.
So what I'll do in merge sort
is the same thing I normally
do, except that I'll
make recursive
routines go in parallel.
So when I do that, it basically
divide and conquers
down, and then it sort of does
this to merge things together.
So we saw this before, except
now, I've got the fact that I
can sort two things in parallel
rather than sorting
them serially.
So let's take a look
at the work.
What's the work of merge sort?
We know that.
n log n, right?
2t of n over 2 plus order n,
so that's order n log n.
The span is what?
What's the recurrence
of the span?
So we're going to take the
maximum of these two guys.
So we only have one term that
involves t infinity, and then
the merge costs us order n,
so we get this recurrence.
So that says that the
solution is order n.
So therefore, the work is n log
n, the span is order n,
and so the parallelism
is order log n.
Puny.
Puny parallelism.
Log n is like, you can run it,
and it'll work fine on a few
cores, but it's not to be
something that generally will
scale and give you a
lot of parallelism.
So it's pretty clear from this
that the bottleneck--
where's all the span going to?
It's going to that merge.
So when you understand that
that's the structure of it,
now you say if you want to get
parallelism, you've got to go
after the merge.
So here's how we parallelize
the merge.
So we're going to look at
merging of two arrays that are
of possibly different length.
So one we'll call A, and
one we'll call B,
with na and nb elements.
And let me assume without loss
of generality that na is
greater than or equal to nb,
because otherwise I can just
switch the roles of A and B.
So the way that I'm going to do
it is I'm going to find the
middle element of A. These
are sorted arrays that
I'm going to merge.
I find the middle element of A,
so these guys are or less
than or equal to a of ma,
and these are greater
than or equal to.
And now I binary search and
find out where that middle
element would fall in the array
B. So that costs me log
n time to binary search.
Remember binary search?
Then what I'm going to do is
recursively merge these guys,
because these are sorted and
less than or equal to ma,
recursively merge those and put
this guy in the middle.
So when I do that, the key
question when we analyze--
it turns out the work is going
to basically be the same, but
the key thing is going to be
what happens to the span?
And the idea here is that the
total number of elements in
the larger of these two things
is going to be at most what?
Another way of looking at it is
in the smaller partition,
if n is the total number of
elements, the smaller
partition has how
many elements at
least relative to n?
No matter where this binary
search finds itself.
So the worst case is sort of
going to come when this guy is
like at one end or the other.
And then the point is that
because A is the larger array,
at least a quarter of the
elements will still be in the
smaller partition.
Of all the elements here, at
least a quarter will be in the
smaller partition, which will
occur when B is equal to in
size to A. So the number, in
the larger of the recursive
merges, is at most 3/4 n.
Sound good?
That's the main, key
idea behind this.
So here's the parallel merge.
Basically you do binary search,
you spawn, then, the
two merges.
Here's one merge, and here's
the other merge,
and then you sync.
So that's the code for the
doing the parallel merge.
And now you want to incorporate
that parallel
merge into the parallel
merge sort.
Of course, you coarsen the base
cases for efficiency.
So let's analyze the
span of this.
So the span is basically then
the span of something of 3/4,
at most 3/4, the size plus the
log n for the binary search.
So the span of parallel merge is
therefore order log squared
n, because the important thing
is, I'm whacking off a
constant fraction
here every time.
So I get log squared n as the
span, and the work I get this
hairy recurrence, that it's t of
alpha n plus t1 minus alpha
n plus log n, where alpha
falls in this range.
This does not satisfy
the Master Theorem.
You can actually do this pretty
easily with a recursion
tree, but the way
to verify is--
we call this technically
a hairy recurrence.
That's the technical
term for it.
So it turns out, this has order
n, just like ordinary
merge, order n time.
here's You can use the
substitution method, and I
won't drag you through
it, but you can look
at it in the notes.
And this should be very familiar
to you as having all
aced 6006, right?
Otherwise you wouldn't
be here, right?
So the parallelism of the
parallel merge is something
like n over log squared n.
So that's much better than
having n order n bound.
And now, we can plug
it into merge sort.
So the work is going to be the
same as before, because I just
have the work of the merge,
which is still order n.
So the work is order n log n,
once again pulling out the
Master Theorem.
And then the span is n over 2
plus log n, because basically,
I have the span of a problem of
half the size plus the span
that I need to merge things.
That's order log squared n.
This I want to pause
on for moment.
People get this recurrence?
Because this is the
span of the merge.
And so what I end up with is I
get another log, log cubed n.
And so the total parallelism
is n over log squared n.
And this is actually quite a
practical thing to implement,
to get the n over log squared
n parallelism versus just a
log n parallelism.
We're not going to do tableau
construction.
You can read that up, that's on
the notes that are online,
but you should read through
that part of it.
It's got some nice animations
which you don't get to see.
This is like when you do longest
common subsequence and
stuff like that, how you
would solve that type
of problem in parallel.
OK, great.